[Musique]
franks entre autres aux mon bonjour
bonjour comment allez vous ça va ça va
vous être candidat pour l'élection
municipale à h el cheikh pour quelle
raison franck sainte-rose heureusement
avez vous décidé de solliciter les
suffrages de la population cherche
airoise
et pourquoi pas aussi voulez vous bien
nous dire très succinctement quel est
votre parcours politique ou associatif
jusque là alors pour parler de moi un
rapidement et gégé 50 ans je vis à la
colline depuis deux mois après avoir
pendant plus de 20 ans habitait à
terville un petit moment à fond là y est
également
je suis marié père de deux enfants qui
ont qui sont nés quasiment à schoelcher
la maternité de pour le ferons
évidemment mais voilà ils ont ils ont
tous les deux grandi à schoelcher et
fréquenté tout le circuit public delà de
la maternelle à au collège à schoelcher
et 7 et je vois dans la vie je suis
cadre territorial je travaille à la
mairie de fort de france depuis un petit
peu plus de deux ans après avoir été
pendant douze ans chef d'entreprise j'ai
avec un petit nombre d'amis au début
fait un certain nombre de constats sur
notre ville voilà et puis chemin faisant
mais ce groupe a grandi s'est élargi
nous avons été rejoints par des
habitants
volonté de celle cher nous sommes
aujourd'hui 84 chez royal chinoise au
sein de l'association les ateliers
chelsea roi et les constats de départ
ils étaient au nombre de deux il était
tout d'abord que alors je vous
interromps parce qu'on va y venir
d'autres questions porte justement sur
les constats que vous avez fait et les
solutions que vous proposez pour
remédier mais certains disent que alors
ne nie pas votre qualité de citoyen des
habitants de deux résidences algérois
mais disent que vous seriez 1 pilotée
par fort-de-france par le ppm parce que
bon justement vous travaillez à la ville
de fort de france avait travaillé à la
cacem un moment vous avez été proche de
deux cherchent de chimie le président du
parti progressiste martiniquais là
dessus qu'est ce que vous répondez quand
vous êtes justement interpellés à tort
ou à raison
j'ai d'abord envie évidemment un temps
évidemment un taux je voudrais rappeler
à auchel xinhua que oui quand j'étais
jeune j'ai milité au parti progressiste
martiniquais
on demande souvent jeunes de s'engager
de faire preuve de des vestes issement
dans la vie publique
et puis une fois qu'ils le font les
critiques non oui j'ai milité au parti
progressiste martiniquais
j'en ai démissionné il ya 12 ans 12 ans
pas deux ans comme d'autres et pas non
plus comme d'autres à être assis au
premier rang
actuellement à tous les congrès et à
toutes les réunions du ppm voilà donc je
suis peut être la dernière personne
qu'on peut suspecter d'être poussés par
le ppm et puis pour répondre à ça la
dynamique que nous portons jolie aile et
les pleinement citoyenne elle est
puissante
elle rencontre l'adhésion des chaînes
géroises l échelle chez roy est vraiment
il faudrait être stupide
j'ose le mot pour avoir fait autant
d'efforts en avoir conçu avec les
chaînes xinhua un projet aussi
intéressant et puis le offrir un parti
politique que qui ne nous a rien apporté
alors le temps passe très vite franck
cette ressource monde donc il nous reste
à peine une minute un tout petit peu
plus d'une minute
donc on va peut-être justement globalisé
les la question suivante quel est pour
vous l'urgence le chantier prioritaire à
la fois pour la municipalité une chaîne
chinoise mais pour aussi l'ensemble des
habitants de cette ville
globalement si vous voulez on va résumer
ça dans les trois grands piliers de
notre projet voilà nous pensons que la
ville de chez le chien n'a pas tenu
l'équipe actuelle en tout cas n'a pas
tenu son engagement de démocratie
participative
nous voulons donc une ville plus
citoyenne qui donne la parole aux
habitants
mais c'est pas une parole en l'air c'est
une parole qui va pouvoir s'exprimer à
travailler à de vrais conseillers de
quartiers qui seront dotés de budgets au
sein du budget du conseil municipal ça
ça peut contribuer à un développement
efficace de toute la ville tout à fait
avec ça serait déjà contribué à
l'apaisement
il vous reste 30 secondes eu de
l'ambiance donc ça c'est la citoyenneté
le deuxième élément c'est la performance
chez le chien est une ville qui a
énormément d'atouts comme beaucoup de
villes un nez - mais l'art université
nous avons palais des congrès nous avons
des hôtels dans une façade maritime nous
avons un arrière-pays magique avec des
producteurs et il n'y a aucune
adéquation entre les politiques
publiques municipales actuellement et la
richesse de notre territoire
il faut remédier à ça le dernier élément
de troisième pilier c'est l'équité il
faut qu'il y ait une justice et un
équilibre dans les décisions qui sont
prises par la municipalité
et c'est aussi là que que qui est
importante
la parole des citoyens voilà ils
s'étaient quittés nous voulons la
restaurer à travers des outils notamment
direction des associations de schoelcher
merci franck se traduire au second
d'avoir participé à ce qu'a dit spécial
municipal donc pour l'élection merci à
la chaîne cher